kip let's talk about that middle-class
famous store baby uh i think you're
talking about buffalo pittsburgh and
detroit that's right we're gonna be
coming to buffalo jumping on the table
detroit we're gonna be hanging out with
eminem and pittsburgh will do a little
coal mining
guys get your tickets it's a great way
to introduce your boys or your gals to
the show
squad grab a cruise send it out in a
group text it's uh me and foley each co
headline t-bones on the show we're
bringing our boy tom cassidy and then we
close it out with a little live ayg with
the crowd you've seen eclipse you know
what we're doing get those tickets the
links in the description do it welcome
to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage little show we sit down
with your favorite comedians and we find
that they grew up to be classy yeah
they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host dave trolley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here at
antodi's basement she's upstairs
starting to go fund me yeah getting some
implants okay
[Laughter]
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he's the ceo of ru garbage
he's international businessman the boys
on wall street call him the gambler
because he likes free drinks give it up
for kj kevin james ryan
i was working it out all weekend this is
amazing i'm not sure i get it what's up
everybody they give you free drinks
you're gambling
but if you're on the patreon you know he
stinks at it ah what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rape if you subscribe on
itunes full video this one is off the
[ __ ] track full video available on
youtube as you know those numbers are
true thank you and i'm contractually
obligated to say uh the greatest website
of all time you should get on over there
you should check it the [ __ ] out it's
www.patreon.com are you garbage the boys
are [ __ ] cooking everything but water
skis over there [ __ ] good time how
about a quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good we love them you love them
yeah give it up for t-bone mcbuttons
thomas mcmullen
what's up what's up
literally had a whole conversation i'm
just like can you just say toby mcmullen
you're a fat piece of [ __ ] yeah
i said your whole proper name i always
forget your middle name yeah but that's
my government name bro that's where
people i owe money to yeah that's how i
screamed my calls aren't anybody looking
for me what the [ __ ] i had a whole thing
i was gonna got a nice popeye with kfc
feels like a neighbor we've never had a
popeye before this is our first pop-up
yeah i like it dropping he's dropping in
i said ben kenobi you [ __ ] what are you
doing to me
i got this psycho looking for me obi-wan
come here
gang we couldn't be more excited to have
our incredibly special guest back back
back with us again today he's family at
this point i mean i just straight up
invited myself on he did no what do you
mean we've been trying to set it up for
a week
i'd say kfc is coming beat it we got the
kid coming in
we were midway through an episode i said
yeah come on stop by we're here joe what
are we here from scarsdale for this yeah
gang he is the brains behind one minute
man sensation
i [ __ ] that up yeah it was a piece of
[ __ ] you were you were working on it
it was the one minute man do i just say
one minute and instead it went minutes
i'm the brains behind one minute man or
i am the one minute man he's but you
went with both you went the brains
he's the brains behind the viral
sensation one minute man there you go i
like that horse the host of kfc radio
ladies and gentlemen kevin francis
clancy
afc
[Applause]
too
you're the listener we're sitting here
before recording having a nice
conversation a little bit of gossip some
hot guys flying around he's over here
googling what the name of the one man
the one-minute man videos are
he's a professional broadcaster i don't
want him thinking bad at me no
he does after that
never never never
never happy to be back
tell us more about how micro dosing
doesn't affect you
run the microdose train oh yeah yeah
okay okay pro macro whatever they got
whatever i can afford that day oh [ __ ]
shout out to them how uh how was your
memorial day how's the summer what's the
scoop bro i
am anti-summer real and it's because of
[ __ ] days like this dude it's a high
one
hot one in the city today 96 is like i
don't get why when it's like zero
degrees people are kind of like you know
you got to stay inside it's you know
it's snowing and it's zero degrees like
just not the reverse
over 90 packets done everybody i would
even argue over 85.
79. i'll see you guys on monday well
what do you keep your apartment at this
is probably good
i have a very busted thermostat i don't
think you're living in a house i live in
a two-family house yeah but it's like an
apartment okay it's not like i know you
have one i didn't know this too i live
in this second
story of a two family house basically oh
one of the cunninghams live downstairs
there there's this older couple there
they're lovely they're are they the
owners no it's uh so i got lucky when
when i split up uh with my wife we sold
the house and then i needed a place to
live and my like family friend is a uh a
landlord and like a contractor and [ __ ]
guys so i got this place it's in the
hood it's garbage but it's uh it's big
it's like a big three bedroom second
floor i hate the walk-up uh it's it's
definitely garbage in that sense but if
window units are central no but so i got
the central there there you go digital
or is it one of those i don't know i got
the digi i got the ditch
here in the clicks like
he's got a steps
like i'm cracking a safe you know i
think it's down to 84.
no but i passed 14. i go 66. i go 62.
i'll go with the window units typically
go down to 62. and if you live in the
city you got it
when i go to the uh when i go to the uh
the the hotel i go as low as it goes
down we went to a hotel recently
and i it just kept going and i think it
hit like 51 or 49 and i was like i was
filming it because every time i go to a
hotel the first thing i do is let's
check it out and it was like 61 58 57
and i was lucky folks we're going into
no man's land like no one the room
starts right here yeah
no man has ever gone this low
uh two things i do when i walk in the
hotel room drop the [ __ ] ac all the
way down and throw on a knee whatever
love that i also love anything anything
on actual old-school cable
channels
i'm away from home i you just traveled
you just got to a bed you go i don't
care what's on just give me [ __ ]
sounds have you ever ordered the hotel
porn no you get your phone what am i
doing yeah but that's what i mean like i
mean like
yeah pretty smart he wants to almost do
that next time like 1999 for like a
softcore porn like let's do it
charge it to the man but you know what i
used to love that they they don't do
anymore uh the robe i used to pop the
hotel robot
robes
my last like three have not had it do
you throw the privacy sign on the door
that's the third thing
i guess i don't but always yeah i would
you know what i i don't go on any
vacations so like the last few times i'm
in a hotel it's for work and i'm just
like i get there i go to our show i
sleep there and i leave like there isn't
much down time yeah but
yeah i would put i would put it up if i
was hanging out you know housekeeping
nope come back later i'm always to come
back later what's the kfc summer
vacation looking like yeah man not much
um not much dude not much you guys are
sticking them on yeah no no you know
what i'm gonna take the kids somewhere
so you know so a couple years ago
we went down to uh the jersey shore last
minute went to bradley beach it was
lovely man nice kind of just kind of
that's exactly it it's sandwiched in
between i want to say like maybe let's
say asbury and like more towards like
the mana squad
so it's kind of like in between the good
ones the popular ones but i'm like ain't
nothing wrong with that with my kids i'm
like they don't get they don't know
they're young they don't give a [ __ ] you
don't have to have something lined up by
now like hey yeah no probably probably
so it's probably it's probably too late
yeah it's probably too late but i was
thinking about maybe just like uh i just
work so [ __ ] much man but i was gonna
try to grab a house in like an airbnb in
august and bring the kids down for like
a long weekend or something
because yeah uh yeah i would probably go
jersey uh what i do though no great
adventure in our dorney park
they're still too young doing that at 96
degrees in august [ __ ] sucks
standing in a line sweating to go into a
pool
food poisoning from some funnel cake
even like i'm at the point like outdoor
weddings and [ __ ] even when it's like
kind of nice out if i'm moving and
dancing and it's outside and there's sun
and it's above like 60 i'm a problem
yeah so i'm like i'm a much i mean i'm
i'm indoor i have a brand bar stool
indoors i am i'm an indoor guy where i
can control it and i got my fridge and
my tv and we can have a grand old time
there i don't hate it i went to a
wedding one time in the summer it was
like the middle of july that the tents
and all that [ __ ] set outside but you
couldn't go into the place there was no
relief oh no [ __ ] that [ __ ] took that
envelope yeah yes right here later
thank you what did i grab cakes what
they did just buy and i'm interested to
know if this is garbage
is we're gonna go out on a limb and say
yeah
well when my kids i don't know uh maybe
not what are you doing this summer
nothing when my kids are going to the
poconos
not even on a lake
or just on the side of the cliff
in airbnb for a long weekend
why do i feel like that's going to
what's your mom's saying
big time single dad vibes we also i did
i mean i know that they had us we also
uh my family lives on in uh city island
in the bronx yeah and at the end of the
block is the beach yeah there you go and
it's like probably the size of this room
the beach and we belong to a club to get
in there literally a gate and then like
private uh public bathrooms and the
beach yeah you have to belong to the
club there but the kids are able to like
go down they think it's amazing yeah
they're very funny we're they're
literally digging in the the grimy you
know long island sound and they're like
the beach it's amazing you stay you're
[ __ ] floating by yeah you stay at
your folks when you go out there uh it's
it's like 20 minutes away so like yeah
yeah i mean uh it no it's not perfect
it's just something something that a
six-year-old and a four-year-old don't
know any better you know what's really
trashy they put out a good king crab
like upstairs
even in the middle of the bronx it's not
what the city is beautiful i i was in
you know i went like you know [ __ ]
look how clear this water is man that's
clean ass water that's not bad for being
in the [ __ ] you can see your face you
can see look at that that's in his
basement dude
goddamn sump pump went again
that was my first experience when i
bought a house so before this apartment
was the first time i bought a house in
the suburbs and
we're trying to be in the nice
neighborhood so we're sacrificing you
know the house itself sure to be in the
and we were we we walked the basement we
see that there's two sump pumps big red
flag
everything was like clean it's like it
wasn't hers what was it the titanic
it was water you expect holy let me tell
you something brother
i swear this thing took on more water
than than the titanic it was this and it
was at the bottom of a hill at the
bottom of the hill at the bottom of it
we did we did the contractor we did the
inspection everyone was kind of like
yeah you know you'll get some
brother a sprinkle and it was [ __ ]
flooded and uh and it's funny because i
used to i was below the water table
i i tried
they blew the levees
[Applause]
i had a person come and i said like what
what could we do to fix this move and
they said we would have to
they said it would be like at least a
hundred grand to you'd have to put it on
like stilts
the driveway went down
right and then there was a garage and
they said we would have needed to fill
in
with cement all of like the driveway up
to the ceiling of the garage so i mean i
it must have been like a zillion tons of
cement to fix this problem so the
solution was move but me being the idiot
that i am and this is this like slave to
see you showing that yeah it's perfect i
swear to god
you need the seven sump pumps i
uh
filmed for social media like all of my
exploits
squeegeeing water into the sump pump me
and these big yellow boots i'm a
homeowner now of course it's scary when
it fills up with water after you figure
you're gonna electrocute it oh i don't
like that at all
and i was like
and so the joke was and i'm so
ill-equipped to be a a homeowner filming
these videos and everything
time comes we got to sell the house i
delete all those obviously
guy who comes through the internet guy
who comes through
went to college with me
knows me
knows the videos and everything
and i don't say nothing and he goes to
me so like
this is what's funny that was all the
production i was doing now but this is
this is where we brought that water in
from the river i i got my my legal hat
on he said um
but he worded it as um has it gotten any
better
and technically it did we took a couple
steps we fixed the pump sure we changed
a couple times
gotten better from the existing
conditions and i was kind of like you
saw these videos homeboy
and he bought it and they already sold
it there was like a couple you know they
were there for a couple years too i mean
it's it needs to be condemned it's a
[ __ ] it's garbage so honestly even
though i'm in the hood in an apartment
right now it's better than than you know
below sea level sure that's a tough look
have you ever peed in the sump pump
that's a that's a great move in high
school or college you're in a basement
drinking oh yeah open up that little
door go to the corner and just [ __ ]
let it rip into something one of the
totally scary spiders coming out yeah
that is 100 spiders huh so i i just
moved into a new place and i have a
question for you as a guy who's gone
from house to an apartment is there
anything in your apartment that makes
you feel elevated that you're like oh
that's a nice touch for me like uh air
fryer or anything like that i did
recently get an air fryer
we got we i just caved yeah
it's i know you were like staunchly
against the entire world it is so good
sorry it's just made the best steak
bites i've ever had in my [ __ ]
leftovers can become a thing now you
know used to be like a soggy this is
gross now you can crisp it up it's nice
um
bro my apartment's so trash i've been
waiting this is this was my divorce he
doesn't have bed bugs how's that yeah
yeah right that's what he did like
this place let me let me let me explain
it because it is nice now but the when i
when when the landlord from the the last
person moved out like when mrs doubtfire
got her place my landlord told me he was
my my family friend he said there was
400 fish tanks in the apartment when he
i'd rather move back under the water
like he went up like uh you know all
right the person's out i gotta like
renovate paint some walls and [ __ ] he
said he had to walk like like excuse me
i just smelled it were they up was the
water in it i think some of them had but
like and then most of them were
interesting was it just finished or was
it also like i thought like uh no
i think it was i think most of them were
literally just the tank like he was
collecting the the
i don't even know what uh but so he he
turtles
out he [ __ ] this guy stinks and
picking properly he cleaned it all out
and everything but then i move in this
is like single dad house to the max and
i'm just trying to get to the finish
line
money and then i can [ __ ] you know
move on
waiting for that check to clear baby
because i'm not gonna go
you know what i mean i don't want to
move a couple times so i gotta wait for
this so i can go get somewhere nice so i
am just like limping to the finish line
here so your answer is no my friend
there's nothing in my apartment the fish
tanks dude that would i'd rather have
the place be haunted yeah that's weird
right that is a weird one you have
anything planned for when you're you
know your number does come in are you
looking i'm thinking what i want to be
thinking like a rancher you know what i
mean you wanna do you wanna like
yellowstone it you wanna like high rise
it like or just like a house in the bird
like what do you think i want a uh i
think the move for me
is gonna be
i never understand people who are like i
got 10 bedrooms and 25 bathrooms sure
unless you got [ __ ] 30 people living
there so i think i'm going to go home a
smaller place
huh are we in that realm no no no no but
i'm saying like nice to know i i'd i'd
rather get a smaller place that's like
tricked out like new modern everything
500 fish tanks
like like motorized blinds yeah
i want i want motorized blinds i want
heated floors i want
dishwashers
floors
to
two dishwashers in the same kitchen
right [ __ ] next to each other so what
because that's new money it's brilliant
this was a bert thing yes it's a life
change it's been debunked no
yeah no what do you to do okay so the
theory is you have two dishwashers and
you never have to empty the dishwasher
one gets full right
you run it
and then you fill the other one and then
that one's done you just keep going back
and forth so you just take it as long as
you you still have to run it and and
like move something but like i said
you're just taking the plates out of the
dishwasher yeah i think it's which is
like the ultimate trash move putting
plates into the [ __ ]
cabinet makes no sense to me next thing
there's a thing that holds it it cleans
it you take it out you eat it you put it
into the other one when that's full
you're running i get that you can't get
away with that as a dad
all right that's never gonna flow that
that that's like still kind of has to be
perfect i agree and then it's it's one
of those it's and also you gotta go
right in the dishwasher and you need two
lines you're gonna need two lines two
different orders listen uh the money's
coming in big man
you ask me what the question is what am
i gonna spend it on two lines of water
that's what i'm spending it on
high roller he's not working for e-bombs
world all right
the last time you were in here i believe
you said you had a tv on the floor yes
i was about to bring that up again when
you said is there anything i'm proud of
i i have a tv on the wall that broke
four years ago i took my other tv i put
it right underneath it so wait so you
have a broken you're did we're talking
about this yeah we did okay that's yeah
broken tv that's probably like a 60
incher that's on the wall
uh and i don't want to
do anything take it off and figure it
out so i just took my team you need a
handy you need like that we've talked
about this the 40 handyman comes over
for an hour and a half zip zap zoom yeah
i understand you don't want to move and
deal with that but it's not like you're
putting in a pool get rid of it
it's a it's a good low rent i don't want
to be the the needy tenant the bothering
you know guys so i just kind of
fly i'm just like i said limping to the
finisher
holy crap
this guy's in a bad way
trouble yeah
pipes are bursts in the house where were
you thinking jersey here new york
it will be westchester that's where this
because that's him as a you know growing
up in the you know i was in the bronx
and westchester yeah that's awesome
that's where you want to go okay so
right now they're in like bronxville
which is you know ah very nice i know
bronxville bronxville and scarsdale look
exactly the same with that
buildings right yeah yeah yeah it's
really nice
bronxville like proper because you know
there's always a thing you know i'm sure
you guys know people who are like i live
i have the address on but it's not the
real thing i have a manhattan dress and
i am not technically a man it's like we
we live in bronx he's not reading the
new yorker yeah i'm not running in the
park every morning all right yeah yeah
let's talk about them helix mattresses
i know you know what i'm talking about
because you got one they sent you one
for free you liked it so much that you
bought one on your own with promo code
garbage you better better believe i
double dipped huh go over there take the
quiz they find out whether you sleep hot
sleep cold whatever you need they got
you straightened out you don't got to
walk around at the a department store
you don't got to walk around a mattress
like a bozo yeah listen
well he said it ten thousand times
because helix is the best me my me my
bird we uh we took the two minutes two
three minutes leave quiz got that
twilight model and i gotta tell you when
kippy go night night he go night night
okay a little twinkle toes ticka ticka
ticky i'm out gold in my in my little
skivvies and my sleeping jeans
sleeps like a dead man in a river
guys i'm telling you listen we got a lot
of bozos out there right i was a bozo
total i got a helix man it's the best
sleep i've ever had it's my first adult
mattress i was always like hey you got
an old mattress pulling it from the
trash the dumpster using my brother's
old while my cousin's getting ready
anybody need a queens i'll take it if
you want to get approved for a mortgage
get a helix
bring the score up a little bit the
kippy guarantee your life will turn
around once you get it once you get a
healing just go to helixsleep.com
garbage take the two minutes sleep quiz
i'll match you with a custom mattress
for the best sleep of your life
uh they have a 10 year warranty and you
get to try it for 100 nights risk free
they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love
them but i'm telling you you will they
even have financing options and flexible
payment plans so a great night's sleep
is never far away here it is here's the
turkey baby he'll sleep
i gotta get through this big man come on
we're not getting paid by the second
over here helix is offering up
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep.com garbage
one more time that's healingsleep.com
garbage do it yeah kev let's talk about
movement movement just a couple of guys
that we're trying to make it in the
world sounds like two guys i know 100
they started a watch company they made
them better they made them cheaper than
the other guy now they're blowing up all
over the place you got to get our
movement it's fantastic yeah it's
bonkers you might be thinking what color
is that i think i don't expect dick
they fair prices are the fastest prices
are the clean original designs are the
cleanest the most original designs
you're going to see top quality movement
mvm write it down get a tattoo
do something one of the fastest growing
bounds shipped over 160 countries across
the globe
they've expanded into blue light glasses
sleek jewelry and even more style
essentials that don't break the bank all
designed out of our california
headquarters that's right there's a lot
of homies and bozos out there too my
girlfriend wears those glasses when
she's on her computer yeah it helps with
the eyes it gives it reduces stress
makes you sleep better the whole nine
years i wear when i'm watching my movies
they sent me a watch and the glasses too
i got my cool fancy watch it's like a
nice uh
kind of tan thing i wear one i call it i
wear canvas bracelets yeah i wear a
light real sharp when i go out to dinner
my fancy dinners i go excuse me you know
what time you know what time it is by
the way
uh i don't know what to do why are you
asking for the time you gotta watch just
to show it flex it these waiters don't
know what's up
uh guys this is it though i think it's 8
30. let me check
[Applause]
the turkey we want to talk about the
turkey this is the turkey
uh
movement is having a huge sitewide sale
for father's day their prices are
slashed up to 40 percent from may 31st
to june 17th so what do you think of it
right now baby go check it out get the
old man something nice make sure you get
the perfect gift for your dad uh from
classic watches
or
shout out joe um they have quality
modern watches at a fair price super
adorable sunglasses the whole nine yards
yeah shop up to 40 off for father's day
uh and save big on the perfect gift for
dad join the movement by going to
mvmt.com
garbage enjoy 40 off again that's
mvmt.com
garbage now back to that show
turkey so uh the if you're in like
bronxville like prop or wrong man or
whatever the [ __ ] it is i think it's
like literally top three in the country
yeah money money yeah goodell lives
there roger goodell damn like big big
money so i'll be next door in the hood
in mount vernon thank you
uh yeah i think so
we we we grew up pool people big time
nice two-car garage
um
probably not no landscaper yeah for sure
landscaper electrician plumber my goal
in life has always been to make enough
money to pay people to do the things for
me i don't do them and you got a car in
mind yeah i know you are a hyundai man
which is a tough look upgrade
[Applause]
which is which is good so 1996
like a kitten no i saw that the the
hyundai experience was a wild one
because i everybody knows i'm a kia man
yeah you you're rolling in it you know
does anybody say anything if they see
you driving around in that they ever say
let me tell you something so i had
pretty delivering pizzas i mean for me
it's on brand
my podcast is about trash and i'm
driving a kiosk listen the experience i
have with cars
so i have the hyundai right
um it's time to turn it in and i got
some nicks and some bumps and it's an
suvs right yeah yeah it's like a
mid-sized suv uh what is it wait what
are the tusks tucson
jesus christ
culture city and arizona a little bit of
culture please visit arizona understand
it's tucson when you do the videos in
the car i'm like what the [ __ ] is that
it looks like you're in a geo tracker
what the [ __ ]
you're like you're like stuck in traffic
there's history in this car
i thought it was like a car he just kept
to shoot videos in to make it seem like
he was still a man of the people and
then he hopped into a helicopter and
flew to bar stool i know i am a man of
the people in that regard i mean this
car had his i was pushing it in the like
on days that would break down i'm
filming myself while i push it to the
same least at least so the lease is
coming up it would break like on your
way into barcelona break down one
specific time uh one criminal let me ask
you this
you guys are you a car guy yeah i need a
car guys all right to me
when the [ __ ] light goes on i'll i'll
try to fix it right really maybe right
no i don't mean like me personally i
mean like the light comes on now there's
a problem yeah of course the like uh
that's a fuse or whatever yeah
but this no lights ever came on
i bring it in they're like you didn't
change the oil i was like well i didn't
[ __ ]
you know show me the oil so i didn't
change the oil uh it was it was probably
you ran out of oil so i like gr like
drove it into the ground with the oil
right so it was like making noise it was
bad i've done that to my chevy lumina
back in the day yeah you were in college
you know when something when it's out of
oil
you know something but it went from like
it was making some noise and
then it was like
and it just kicked out i yeah listen now
i know i got to change it regularly if
the light doesn't go on i don't do
anything i i understand that too yeah if
you're not if it's not something you're
like thinking about and you go oh i will
be prompted to ch like oil life five
percent like all right let me go also in
my mind i was like it wasn't that long
ago this is for everything i think
hyundai's have that technology though
you know what i mean because my kia
doesn't either i went i didn't change it
for like five or like six eight thousand
miles and i was like oh [ __ ] never
prompted me yeah there's no warning
light in that thing that's what i'm
saying though it's like i don't fix [ __ ]
unless it's [ __ ] broken
and uh this is broken sure so you know
things like that anyway now you're an
affordable heavyweight no but so i i i
sorry so the car is banged up and i
i give it to i have a friend who has a
shop he was like i'll fix it for you so
when you turn it in you don't have to
pay for any of these little damages
whatever turned out one of the pieces
was like more broken than we thought on
the grill and we needed to order it and
i knew about this supply chain and [ __ ]
bro jm job i was that no not even he was
a good guy i was just it was just in the
shop for three months yeah it was two
two months what are you laughing at
that's
trying to piece together the grill was
busted
so so i so the i had like four cars in a
matter of two months because i had a
rental but the rental ran out after 30
days then i had to uh then i was
basically like i was riding dirty i had
enterprise on my ass being like you got
to bring this car back and i was like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah my dad did that
they were showing up to find the car
yeah so he had it for like how many days
did you push oh i i probably went over
probably like three weeks with it can't
they just
yeah yeah can they just charge you for
it so they were gonna charge me for it
dog my buddy was an uber driver he
leased through uber he couldn't afford
the payments he just left it at a gas
station
and called uber it was like it's at the
sick go on all sides
you can keep the jolly ranchers
that's the louis vuitton it's like well
you're gonna go get it
i'm out of here no sweat off my back uh
as as they were like you got to bring it
in they were like we can extend you
don't worry we're figuring out as that
happens my license expires so now i got
the dmv on my back i've got hyundai on
my back because now it's time for the
lease to expire the dmv is like your
your license expired the car lease is
expired the rental car is expired i'm
sitting here fighting for my [ __ ]
life
war over here
and then
if people ever say anything to me while
this is all happening my uncle is like i
got you we have a a car you can borrow
you're riding a bike like this
because now so yeah rental is
my insurance won't pay for any more
rentals so i gotta rent the car 200 a
day you know i can't do this i i got the
money yet man when the insurance company
turns their back on you 2 000
listen i can give you i can i can give
you a neon for two days but then that's
all i can do well it wasn't much better
it was a 2010 prius
man you gotta rep the upkeep exactly you
have like five billion impressions oh
i'm driving and you're [ __ ] listen
don't ever tell me i don't let anybody
ever tell you i'm not the common man all
right i'm keeping it real over here i
don't think even the real goes wrong
i go to the mets game opening day and uh
as we're leaving i'm driving out of the
parking lot and you know when you're
getting out of a ballgame if you drive
there it's like you just you're just in
dead traffic trying to get out of the
parking lot nightmare and i see these
guys because i have this silly mets hat
that i wear that my son bought me that's
big and oversized so they see like my
hat and they're like yo it was like kfc
and i'm like yeah man like good win you
know people are still riding a big wheel
what's going on and then they go
it goes from so quick of like yo man
like love your [ __ ]
are you driving a prius what are they
paying you at barstool man and i'm
sitting there like like please can the
traffic just go away can i drive around
it it's a bad look i've always had the
car and me has been a running thing of
barcelona forever i had a fiat back in
the day that i got made fun of
relentlessly for who
because i got 99 a month parking uh the
only other other person i know who drove
a fiat did the same thing so i was able
to six months of free parking zip back
and forth we got a year on an upper east
side of uh parking garage that was
usually like seven hundred dollars a
month we lived in western i couldn't
turn it
down how was it it was a hell of a
commute
i'm not a car guy though so like and
then and then the so when the lease is
expired i went out there i was thinking
like i'll go to a couple dealerships
i'll do a little comparison i'll get the
car
everyone was like you're not driving off
the lot today are you nuts there's no
cars available and i knew it was bad but
they were like you can go akia the kia
truck or suv thousand dollars a month
damn and they were like and it'll be
available in three weeks i was like suck
my dick that's crazy so these guys know
shout out to my guys at uh all american
ford out in jersey don't bleep that
i'm a rockledge kia man myself wherever
the [ __ ] it's jitty island jfp kerbach
that's what they're doing here they they
hooked me up they actually told me how
shitty is this they were like uh in
other years if the world was a different
place we would just give you a car yeah
and he's like but we can't we just can't
anymore there's supply issues and money
issues and [ __ ] so we can give you the
friends and family but they were like
ordinarily we would just be like can you
post about us on social media and here's
your car and i was like [ __ ]
any other year that would have just been
you know they could went to pete alonso
they do these guys i would have made the
cut i would have been somebody that was
the thing my friend was like i was
telling this whole saga to my friend and
he was like don't can't you just like
get a car from somebody can't you use
this i was sitting there like yeah maybe
i should do that yeah i don't parlay
enough of this you know in a monster
energy car
[Laughter]
i gotta drive around times square an
hour a day but that's it other than that
we're good who's that in the jacklinks
car what's going on
so you what do you have you have an
explorer
ford explorer what's the year
new brand new 2023 really yes it's not
at least i'm a least
and then give it back you know there you
go unless you're a real car guy would
you have your heart set on something
which i just don't i mean i guess if i
got this money i you know uh what would
be my dream car i don't i don't even
have a dream car like i can't even i
don't know i like audi's maybe i get a
nice audi i don't know [ __ ] it's not
like i'd be like the 1967
shelby gt with the racing strips
i like how you're talking about the
money like you're a dock worker and like
it's like a lottery yeah so that's like
when my number comes in it's coming i
mean uh you know what
is it though is it foley
is it you look at some every time every
time barcelo's back in the news i'm like
i'm dodging a bullet here i just gotta
make it to february 2023 please [ __ ]
god and i always got portnoy being like
you know i've made you rich beyond your
wildest dreams like no not yet i heard
you yelling at [ __ ] i saw a clippy you
yelling you're like well i don't have it
yeah when it's in my account then but
until those days i'm driving a hyundai
doosan
what is the dream then if you if it's
not a car it's not like a super lavish
place he told you two dishwashers
this bozo i want four refrigerators i'm
gonna have one for soda one for candy
gonna have to run it by the landlord but
he seems like a good guy
i i do have like so back to the hou i
just want a house that's like
i want it to just be exactly you know
it's like i want my fridge in my living
room near the tv
i want my you know i i don't want it to
be like a regular house i want it to be
like every [ __ ] who are you
herman what do you what do you want to
do that's what the kid in black check
did you know what yeah yeah that's what
i mean though what are you talking about
the traditional
man that's trash you want to put the
refrigerator in the living room
what happens when the kids bring friends
over you can't get your house on pimp my
ride
yeah that's what i want that's exactly
what i want we got 20s in the windows
bathroom inside your living room dog we
got the kitchen inside the bathroom
inside the bedroom dog
i heard you like dishwashers oh we got
the dishwasher in the bed dog
[ __ ] dude you like sports there's a
batting cage in the bedroom
i mean i don't have i i am a very simple
man the whole thing is not gonna be a
big
i've always said
thank you kevin i appreciate that
uh i've always said uh i always just
wanted enough money to have like a beach
house so well this is give me a second
house i was just down the shore and i
think
you can't afford i can't i mean i can i
can't afford a house anywhere for the
unless it's like the poconos or
something but i think my move is gonna
buy i'm gonna buy a shore house first
yeah and then because i have a really
good deal on rent here and just rent and
then we've talked about because that's
what a lot of people in new york do
because you can't afford to buy in new
york so they're like we buy a vacation
home or a second home you can find it
out a little bit or if you're just
gaining equity that's not a bad idea
especially if you've got money and you
don't if you're not married or kids or
all that [ __ ] yet it's like you don't
really need like the home in westchester
you're not worried about schools yeah
yeah so go get a house in the hamptons
go to house in jersey still live in your
apartment north wild new jersey baby i
wasn't looking this weekend don't open a
house hold on so i should keep my
apartment in queens
and it's not that bad and buy a house in
hawaii there you go well i mean that's a
jump because it's going to take it's
going to cost you three grand to get
there everybody but you rent it out the
other you know 360
360. i make the rules on airbnb smoke
anywhere you want
did i tell you the the shirt was such a
hit
at the fillmore man thank you people
were like oh my i mean everybody noticed
it it was great everybody pointed out
the king did you tool around philly a
little bit what'd you do uh we we went
to uh the barstool has a bar in philly
yeah they just they just opened it
apparently you know i'll shoot you
straight when people you want to go to
the barstool bar i was like not really
to be honest let's go to like a real
company man
you're just talking about the stock tank
and you're over here
in there pump some [ __ ] drinks shake
some hands what are you doing
[ __ ] work their merch table or
something it's your children's future
for god's sakes
you're gonna be about
to join
jesus i've done enough done enough uh
but i i i everybody in philly was like
no no like this is the bar we would go
to anyway mario
i would say backwards uh big nice bar
like good vibes good music good good
everything good so we had a blast there
i saw the boys the next day and they
were talking very yeah yeah we had a
bunch of you know gillis and uh the
stuff island boys were all there
yeah it was cool i mean granted we were
getting endless buckets of [ __ ]
seltzers and booze and beer just you
know in the vip but it looked like you
know it was it was a cool spot so it
would be so funny if you couldn't get
the vip in the bar store if somebody
else had it you're like what the [ __ ]
you gotta do around here
[Laughter]
to show you how little we are like uh
like bar stool money like rich and and
you know living the dream type [ __ ]
you've covered it so far fight over yeah
final bird goes to me
like guy like this is going to be such a
big bill i was like
i don't think we're paying for it yeah
we're at a bar store i was like this is
but then i was like but are we [ __ ] are
we because we brought a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah so i said like i did i did tip the
waitress cash on the spot because i was
like someone's gonna [ __ ] this girl and
not give her her money but i was like oh
my god and we had to have a little pow
wow with the the general manager being
so is this taken care of and he was like
yeah yeah dude what are you [ __ ]
idiots
because we're just we're just not like
those people i don't know of course
imposter syndrome or whatever we're just
not those guys i love it i don't think
anything's gonna change other than like
i'll be relaxed i just won't worry like
the kids are good the college is good
like i'm still gonna be you know [ __ ]
streaming stranger things i don't know
what about what about mets boxed seats
i'm not there you go no you don't you
probably don't like going to the games
yeah i get on the team i don't go we go
we go to our events
he doesn't like anything i love him but
he doesn't like anything he's in his
chair with his big mets hat on yeah
so you've got a refrigerator right next
to him i mean if i had a sweet or
something like that but like it's it's
more about getting to the it's a lot
especially in cities if you live outside
of the city it's brutal man you're
either gonna drive in the traffic and
all that [ __ ] or or you know i'm too
rich to be taking public transit at this
point in my fantasy so um
you know it's like seinfeld has a box
that he just like never is ever in
inside in city field he has this
beautiful
you know and it's like i guess maybe i
would have one in case i wanted to go
but no it's not that it's uh it's it's
like the nice beach house i i will go if
i get a beach house i will that's where
i will be you know like most of the time
i can be there that's where i'm gonna
live you know that'll be my dream and
the rest will be like now i have money
to pay these [ __ ] bills yeah
lord knows there's a lot of them man
some pump bills are adding up let me uh
i forgot about that story already that's
insane all right you ready for
i need the verdict
oh no bad dude i get the comfort you're
a titan of industry what are you doing
dude they're glittery people know you
out there
so these were this is uh
there's like a street two shoe sizes on
the bottom it's a 10 and a 12. that's a
[ __ ] answer well that's because it's
men and women's it's unisex i'm
surprised you didn't say whistle pig on
the bottom of the cell to be quite
honest hey t-bone can you zoom in on my
whistle pig crocs
so i i'll be honest
hit me up
i could use can you just cut that out
that's mine
could use a couple of big bucks floating
around
a couple of pork dollars i i bought it
kind of as a joke and what this is the
reason why it's like shiny and [ __ ]
there's a street wear and like sneaker
designer uh called jeff staple and he
made these these are the new york city
additions so you know when this the
sidewalk has a sparkle
and his thing is he has the pigeon
that's like his logo so he designed
these right so i i kind of get him
clem is another guy at parcel who is
he's leading the the crocs charge he's
like yeah listen you're gonna talk your
[ __ ] you're gonna make fun of it you're
gonna slide them on you're gonna love
them and it's exactly what happened
and now it's the summer and it's i'm
always like what do i i don't like
flip-flops not a flip-flopping guy
sweating in there no cause look man it's
got the [ __ ] you know got the air
conditioning in there it's got that i
don't know man i don't i i i get like if
you run to the store or something i'll
give you that but that's what
you just traverse to the city yeah well
i got my indoors and on my outdoors you
know what i mean that i don't like it
that's i i don't like them i'll i can
never do them you didn't find them at
least
because i was that guy i was that guy
you're i was this guy too i was the guy
who was like no
i mean i have a i have 115 pairs of
sneakers in my house the one that's the
one thing i i buy is speakers right and
so i was the ultimate edition crocs now
i'm like you know what
i don't know i can't do it i tried to
get away with it for for about 10
minutes there's one sitting right there
yeah the other one who knows where the
other one is why you didn't like it but
they [ __ ] made fun of me gave me an
eating disorder what are you talking
about ridiculous so so you like that's
crazy like you just i feel like if you
don't like them i feel like i'm standing
in a ball pit it's real squishy
i don't like it yeah
well then you get those at the croc
store that was like a custom job no it's
not a custom for me he he so this is the
other thing too everyone makes fun of
crosstalk you knew the guy no no well i
mean i know who he is he's like famous
but but he put them on you know he
bought them on sale yeah definitely your
most garbage appearance i know this is
crazy
i wore them i'm ready i came in with
everything i'm coming in hot uh um
so i was like why don't we do uh a
collab with crocs barstool and crocs
because i wear them clem wears them as a
bunch of guys at barstow who are like we
don't [ __ ] care what you guys think
we're gonna wear these comfortable shoes
and uh i was thinking to myself
crocs would be like oh my god like we
love this like you've got some young
audience you've got some guys that you
know the people who always say i would
never wear it if the barstool guys saw
it maybe they would i'm thinking they're
gonna roll out the red carpet
laughed in our [ __ ] face
said maybe
maybe we will talk to you have a
conversation with you in two years
because the next five six seven eight
seasons we are already uh like booked up
with huge collaborations whatever yeah
with balenciaga
so crocs is like get ahead make fun of
us all you want we're busy working with
like italian you know fashion houses
sure the [ __ ] out of here
how about a full croc suit well what do
you guys think why stop there right just
become
but this is definitely a part of like
i've given up you know i'm saying yeah
and that i think that's the scary part
to me the second i i don't like i don't
wear sweatpants in public i'm like
you're just you're in shape though so
you get away with a [ __ ] this is the
time
like like five years ago athleisure
became a thing where you can wear
joggers and sweatpants and [ __ ] in
public and it's like cool but you missed
the window he wouldn't look like that i
know you got you got good legs you're
still you're still your legs are all
right that's [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy are
you kidding me what are we doing dude
you got nursing home like my legs are
all right me and you were the same i'm
skinny fat i'm not every i'm not
impressed
he's let's get some of that money get
out of here
he's taller and slicker he can pull it
off
nobody's looking at me being like you
look great in those [ __ ] you know
sweatpants and crocs it's just that it's
like when kanye's
wearing jeans to fly i refuse to wear
sweatpants really i'm jeans in case i go
in casey
i don't know okay let me i gotta do this
i hear your family funeral you know they
found them in sweatpants oh dude yeah my
uncle then would be in the back like you
heard her
he was in he was in basketball
if this isn't what he had
[ __ ] um
main character syndrome i think they
call it where they you know you like who
you think people are looking at you
whether you're wearing jeans or
sweatpants being like that it's more of
a mental thing of like i'm working like
it that doesn't make any sense i don't
know i get it it's like it's their own
but to me it'd be like
instructions like get like new balances
you're that just like doesn't work you
should get over this bro let me ask you
this you should get over this i agree
dude i i moved in a swimsuit this
weekend
i was gonna ask him if he's wearing a
bathing suit
i'm legit once lululemon do you own a
bathing suit yeah uh you can get a bell
at the barstool stores
that's not fair
no no we need new colorways he's selling
everything without the net by the way i
hate the net
yeah no net yeah i'll cut a net if i
have to always cut it just you don't
have to do that always cut the neck no
net in mine so all winners like board
shorts board shorts but they're not
because shorts are now out of style
they're too long and [ __ ] like that
you know we work this job this life to
not have to of course dress
in business casual and look you know so
and and then and then along comes
athleisure and kanye west and all these
people who say that sweatpants and
hoodies and all that [ __ ] are cool and
stylish and fashionable
[ __ ]
this is the time i get it i get it yeah
cause you know what in another you know
seven eight ten years where they're like
now you gotta wear a full suit
everywhere you go or some [ __ ]
that's what i'm talking about out of
denim or something something sturdy
something very comfortable
currently well not maybe not because of
the summer but this spring was wearing
corduroy pants yeah yeah yeah that were
they were baggy it looked like a
skateboard seattle in the night or a guy
who you know was like
for a guy who was like you gotta wear
your you know skinny jeans with the peg
at the bottom you got to roll it up and
it's got to be this and that now he's
like well you know fashion changes and i
wear [ __ ] boat sails of i mean he has
like reams of fabric of corduroy on his
legs [ __ ] that just pop on your go to
the barcelona
did you have a cheesesteak or anything
in philly so disappointing man i uh i i
uh i i used to live outside of philly so
i i know a little bit about the
cheesesteak game it's my favorite
sandwich in the world i don't know much
about like as much about in the city
because i was a kid going in it was more
like we had our favorite spots in the
suburbs appetites delight and barwin
pizza and some of these they're not
famous but they're my favorite spots
uh i have a theory
i'm listening that these
these spots we were uh where did i go
i want to say it was like a spin-off of
gyms gyms in old town or something like
that like there's gyms but then there's
another gyms maybe i don't know if
there's multiple gyms there's jim's on
south right
yeah that might have been it is that
jim's on set the only time he's like a
50's diner a little bit yeah it's like
four straight there's nothing
okay so i went there a lot of heroin
addicts walking around yeah
uh and
all the ingredients are good and [ __ ]
it's fine i think these places are so
popular and they're moving so fast that
they they put the cheese on the bread
and they put the bread on top of the hot
meat and that's supposed to give you
like the melt sure i need the cheese and
the shredded meat mixed in and which is
what you get in the philadelphia suburbs
yes yes that to me 100 percent a
thousand times better because in the
city you get the meat with a little bit
of melted cheese and then a little bit
of like regular cheese and it's fine
because you're still eating meat and
cheese is a good sandwich yeah yeah but
i to me i want it's the soft roll the
gooey melted in cheese the best one
barry steaks on long beach island
barry's batteries
they're my absolute favorite and it was
originally one of these have they have
like 51 flavors of ice cream and then
they became a food place they came to to
to barstool with cases of cheese steaks
in like these nasa wrapped foil things
to keep them warm and all that even
traveling you know two three three and a
half hours from from long beach island
they were still
fire and that's because of the mix in
with the goo there's a lot of places uh
such as steve's which i'm a fan of um
i was like in the northeast but then
there was one in the center city but
they closed during the pandemic uh a lot
of people say steve's is the best
obviously it's debatable but they do
melted american so they have a tub of
hot melted america that's what you need
they just [ __ ] yes
that's why that's why i exclusively go
whiz
you get your cheese fries on the side
with a side of melted american for the
fries as well
the the way if you can turn
uh the the american and even the
provolone into the whiz yeah they just
the whiz
they have american liquid provolone also
gives you this the stretchy gooey
extreme so you should maybe do a little
combo but i think a lot of the city
places are either so big and they're
going you know they're just like that's
next next qualities they're not taking
all the time
but it's not even quality it's just like
because the meat and all that [ __ ] is
quality degrees it's just that they
don't take the assembly sure
also i'm a big i'm a big profounder you
can go into pretty much oh you know you
can go into a lot of just like bodegas
or corner their corner stores in
philly
the sandwiches up here stink yeah
manhattan
is the deli's in manhattan it's it's
over see they do the jewish delis the
cats
are now bodegas yeah but with like a
deli counter you go across the the the
river to jersey and you go to my home
i mean they are sure
fiori's biacomanos paparazzis they the
the mozzarella that they make in fiores
and hoboken oh my god yeah i could you
know that's what i want i want i want i
want i want that i want an apartment
made out of this [ __ ] delicious yes
it's crazy how hard you know it's like
if i'm in manhattan i'm going to like
lenny's you know like a chain it's like
you know like what what's like your good
italian go-to deli in manhattan they
don't exist
you're going to blimpy no you know what
i'm a subway guy if i'm going to one of
those places i'm with you are you ever a
quiznos guy big quiz no
not big on the toasted sandwiches no me
neither i like the cold of course yeah
do you want sandwiches
yeah they almost automatically assume
now yeah they really do also i don't i
t-bones losing a [ __ ] over there
don't they don't don't they just toast
it in that oven the one they run it
through is all right like the grill like
the rack that's a little different than
throwing in that weird mic has a
microwave that can heat up it's a
convection oven yeah
yeah there's like a weird mat or
something on there yeah
duncan does the same shovel like that
though yeah
i've said i've been on record duncan
stinks in new york they know their way
around the hash browns
food in new york city
service
dirty but like they're they're [ __ ]
like their coffee's not free so i
wouldn't know that but to me it's like
things when i see people getting like a
egg sandwich a dunk and i'm like well
that's on you brother sure you know your
donuts are fine but you're getting if
you're getting the hashtags
they're bacon egg and cheese on a
croissant i wouldn't kick out of bed i
could say that right now i'm supposed to
do that maple bacon yeah
yeah whatever yeah but it's made in a
microwave
they just stand there with their hand on
the microwave waiting for it to beep
it's the worst [ __ ] i want process
ever the thing at subway i don't know if
they make them out of yoga mats whatever
they make them out of that bread is soft
and the smell is intoxicating and then
you put it in the uh the microwave thing
and it becomes you know flaky and crispy
and it's like that's yes i want it soft
i understand what you're doing right a
heated sandwich done right is certain
what's your go-to at subway you ever
[ __ ] with the crab salad or the tuna
salad oh that was a big debate
that was a big debate about a month ago
feidelberg got a tuna sandwich
you got a tuna wasn't it not tuna yeah
it come out yeah no it's not definitely
that's why it's important yeah it's not
tuna it's like dolphins and bottle caps
there's an earring in here he ate it
when he was like hungover and then he
had like it left over and he and he's
complaining about his stomach hurting
i'm like yeah you [ __ ] think you're
reading
imitation
subway come on
it was not
i could be wrong it's got no it it
definitely is like one of those things
where they can't they don't call it tuna
fish they call it tuna it's like it's
like fish random meat with fish flake
powder smushed up yeah god damn it i saw
something uh i saw a truck
that overturned and like they said
something like
like i was in philly 1500 pounds of hot
dog food
no it was like 15 000 tons of hot dogs
yeah that was just
pennsylvania that picture was unreal
it looked like a fat guy exploded
i did somebody hit a foley on i-95
jackknifed tractor trailer
no my go-to would be um when i go to the
subway it's either i do the italian bmt
which is like an italian combo yeah i go
with the sweet peppers lettuce tomato
and a [ __ ] ton of oil vinegar i want it
to be like the bread is soggy okay or i
would do uh
turkey american bacon like a turkey club
basically i respect it with double bacon
double cheese but that's where they
always want to put it in i'm like no
microwave the bacon
because one time i said i don't want it
you don't want the whole sammy and they
just they just but they didn't cook the
[ __ ] bacon like you got to still cook
the bacon can't get good they're not
doing it they must have looked at you
like you were an alien come on they're
not making hot and cold sandwiches over
there
if i'm going to a deli though like a
real deli chicken cutlet
uh i need to do a chicken cola with
mozzarella and balsamic
or i'm doing like uh
you know what's an underrated one that i
rock with
uh monster cheese chicken cutlet with
monster cheese you know what's making a
comeback too that pepper jack stuff
pepper jack give a little bit of a bite
a lot of people you know a lot of people
don't don't
they stick to like american or swiss or
whatever it's a whole world of cheese
out
there honey sandwich cheese shop down
there in a village blow your [ __ ]
hair baby you got everything all right
everything they have to go with the
cheese i don't have it on sandwiches but
goat cheese on appetizers oh yeah it's
basically kind of like cream cheese it's
like cream cheese that you're allowed to
eat on other [ __ ] yeah oh so underrated
man cheese is where it's at subway
lawsuit
got thrown out because it was uh the
study that said it wasn't the study said
they didn't detect 100 tuna dna but it
was after it was cooked so that so that
changes the the dna properties so it was
a bunch of stuff also
if you cooked me i'd come up as a human
and i don't like that we have to go to a
dna test yeah what is this [ __ ] mori
what's going on
you are not the tuna did they catch it
on a boat did it look like a fish what
are we doing today i feel like they
should throw out the thing they should
throw that out being like we're throwing
out the case because you're an [ __ ]
if you eat tuna fish from subway you
like you know what i mean like we're not
it's not like you're under the
impression you're getting a five-star
meal whether it's real or not you know
you're in here
fish you must acquit
we're all dirt balls also who takes that
case on that's great yeah right that's
some jackie child [ __ ]
that's great your face is my kiss
the man's a guy you know that's some guy
who's like it's a class action we've got
millions of people in the tournament
we're gonna make we're all gonna be rich
my boy called me and was like yo did
your facebook money come in and i was
like what he's like from the from the
lawsuit from three years ago you didn't
get it there's a website you can go to
and put your name and or something in
it'll tell you like anything you qualify
for of like something i mean hey free
money's free money government owes you
some money or like whatever you can go
throw your name see that i don't like to
do though because then i feel like i'm
like on their radar that's how you get
you yeah
yeah that's like the money i didn't know
i have yeah right that's like when a
teacher says like i'll review
your test but then it's open to me
reviewing everything you know what i'm
talking about yeah it's like i don't
want you looking at i'm good i'll take
the mesophilioma i don't yeah keep it
like a bank job dude just don't toast my
sandwich i was laughing at the other day
i'm driving and i see on the back of the
bus 1-800 divorce
like if you're calling one eight hundred
divorce yeah you're generally you're
losing like you just just give her the
house bro like you ain't winning i
forget where i was i think we're uh
we're at a club club down south
somewhere at a comedy club and i was
peeing in the bathroom and over the
urinal they had like it was like a
lawyer's advertisement and it was like
it was like johnny the lawyer uh it's
like dui's 299 dollars domestic abuse
four hundred and five dollars yeah like
all this [ __ ]
god damn dude this dude really knows his
market you know there's a guy peeing
like yep yep yep exactly
kill a dog fifty eight dollars
two for one deal right now summer beat
up your neighbor's kid
if you're a lawyer with a prefix menu
no substitutions
oh we got to do a couple of questions
all right this is one's from uh before
we get started you know what turks and
caicos is by any chance yeah okay just
checking the ebony stink um t-bone had
no idea what it was the fanciest thing
i've ever done i went to the left and
came into like a five star you went to a
furniture store
toby thought person was a furniture
store no i made a joke i was like i was
like oh whoa yeah yeah yeah like selena
and barnes they're uh you know a legal
duo
yeah
it sounds like beer one i was like
he said would you get an end table we
were like we didn't even understand we
were like what are you talking to me i'm
like no i went to like the most
beautiful beaches you've never lived in
a world where
somebody didn't understand yeah that's
that's a while i like how you know
that's an all-inclusive character
we're taking a flight down to selena
will go off season he can get a good
deal
comment if you don't know what the [ __ ]
if you've never heard of turks bro
there's going to be not going to be a
single comment you're just lining
yourself up together
you think you're going to win this
argument you lived in florida too this
guy changed his patreon name to turks
and bozos
that's one guy you will lose this
argument harder than anyone's lost an
internet internet argument ever you're
going this is crazy it's like not
knowing like the bahamas that's coming
from this guy you really [ __ ]
you're really
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] i'm happy i came in with so
much garbage because i was saying i'm
blowing my first appearance i think you
guys it was like kissing your mother it
was like i'm not it was a little but
you're not garbage
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i know he has a guy for every carpet
something a good idea
well shelley's not driving that much
anymore so i guess you can
grandma with your cataracts what are you
crazy all right let me take the lawn
mower all right this one is uh this is
went to see top going with my grandpa he
ate his share of the popcorn i guess
they split a bag you know what i mean he
had a share of his popcorn using his hat
as a bowl lined with napkins trash or
innovation i like it i have a feeling
you're on board with that absolutely
that's crazy
he said his grandfather right
grandfather that's what i'm on board
yeah just being like you're a grandpa
and you're like i'm wearing my crocs so
i got my hat bowl uh i'll put it you
know i'll put it in my shirt like this
yeah he's not reaching his hand in the
same bag that the kids are reaching into
i know that is that's correct i don't
know oh you know what i got for you i
think i would rather just do that this
one is gonna this is gonna update the
garbage
a whole extra level i went to the movies
to see
doctor strange so maybe the white like a
month ago through snuck in
i uh i ordered a glass of milk oh i saw
this did you see that they were tagged
in that mm-hmm that's pretty crazy but
they had it how did they have it they
have a whole menu man i mean to be
honest wait a whole menu of what dairy
products you can get like no dessert in
order to get food you get steak you can
get booze you can get everything okay
and to be honest the the this the milk
came first so i had a picture of just
the milk i was getting hot chocolate
chip cookies is it always a little bit
better but for the content of it all
right look at me i'm drinking milk
that's what that's awesome look at the
movie theater is wild is that the texas
roadhouse or what's up it's called the
alamo the alamo draft house that's what
you're thinking about it's awesome man
yeah it is it's old school i mean you
can get like buffalo wings and some of
it's honestly a bit much i don't want to
go sit down and eat a [ __ ] skirt
steak at the movie theater you know
either but crazy to me but
for me
like i'm also like pop who had the
hanger right here yeah
this is well i asked for medium [ __ ]
you write it on this little piece of
paper and then you put like your it's
almost like uh the brazilian steakhouse
is where you put the red and the green
thing up so totally i haven't gone but i
want to i love when that you know you
can eat like endless [ __ ] pounds of
meat it's like i don't want to eat them
yeah no but they you can get like these
cookies that come in like the cast iron
skillet and you can
get some nice [ __ ] like that you know
rather than i i myself takes away from
the movie no i understand what you mean
like you're like looking for the waiter
you're like no they're pretty good
because you just you do it you put it
there and they kind of just run yeah
it's a distraction it's a little bit it
is a little bit but on the flip side
you're getting like a nice glass of milk
yeah yeah to me you know i go to the
movies i guess sorry sorry for two
percent
can you imagine sending something it was
[Laughter]
i almost did have a complaint you know
they brought the milk and then the
cookies were like 20 minutes later so
the milk was warm is the whole thing oh
my god
no but uh
i'm trying to be a dirt ball all at once
yeah
holy [ __ ]
i'm a
popcorn with bunch of crunch when the
like the mix yeah well i i just eat i
don't i don't like to pour it in yeah
and then i'm without him drinking a
gallon of soda
milk when the milk gets warm when the
milk gets room temperature i don't mind
that i'll still use it as it'll get fuzz
on it i'll just oh what i'm kidding
no i don't mind it oh that's another you
know feidelberg had he was he had like
the tuna sandwich and then he drank
spoiled milk and then he had like
chinese that was like five days old and
then he's like oh my belly hurts yeah
he's a [ __ ] friend yeah he plays
i told him i said if we slice you open
like license plates
that little kitten boy would fall out
of the mind that once you are like 80.
you're anything i think you can do
anything you can eat out of your hands
yeah
racial terms you're doing sexist terms
you're saying whatever you want it's
like i don't [ __ ] know man it's good
stuff what's next uh all right this
one's from husky jeans never had a
question red have you or anyone in your
family ever brought an air mattress to
the beach bonus points if you took that
bad boy in the water to catch some waves
not a bad idea also many people chimed
in and were like best summer of my life
best beach trip ever that i've done it
i have not but it's like the wheels are
spinning yeah just to sit on it on the
beach but you gotta you gotta uh i get
that i guess you gotta bring a little
battery powered
pump a lot of people have like the
battery to pump the batteries
i mean listen
up like an [ __ ] yeah
you take it to the gas station then
strap it to the top of the car equally
like you're sitting on the beaches
yeah it's a bad luck so that's garbage
yeah but i'm also like when you go to
the beach with kids now
it's gotta be whatever it is whatever to
keep
or whatever it's like
we're building this bed for my [ __ ]
kids so they leave me the [ __ ] alone you
know i have to do it this weekend with
my niece and nephew do i need to get a
tent
i see i do the tent because it's like
otherwise i'm gonna be putting sunblock
on you fifty [ __ ] you do like a
second you do like that because you're
gonna get somebody watching like a
soccer game like an intramural soccer
game or like a camping tent no no
to be honest i'm a pool guy no surprise
sure so they go a lot with their mom but
they do like uh the pot like four sticks
or snakes that's why i was just at the
beach that's that's the way you gotta
hump that thing over you're like [ __ ]
normal
and then you open it up you gotta you
gotta crank it in
corkscrew it in so that it doesn't blow
away you got the stakes in the ground
and it's like you got to fill up a
bucket full of sand ty you got to anchor
it yeah big thing it's not exhausting
i'm just going to take them to a bar
yeah it's i mean beach with the kids is
let's do this when you're 12.
i see that then you get there and
they're like i want to go [ __ ] i see
moms and dads in the airport with like
just bags and the kids it is dude i
would [ __ ] blow my brain that's the
main reason i got to get out of this
joint at the place i live in now because
i gotta walk up the stairs so i get both
these kids fall asleep on the way home
oh yeah i got two kids i got the bag i
got the grocery bag and i'm getting the
keys out to get in it's like you can't
leave one in the car run one up i just
sometimes just leave them in there for
the
it's night they're good don't worry it's
illegal on my ford explorer when i get
out of the car now it says
and it says check clear yeah occupants
oh really i know a guy my buddy he takes
his shoe off puts it in the back so he
doesn't forget his kid because that you
get out of the car you're like oh i
don't have my shoes that's crack crazy
what the [ __ ] yeah listen i've heard
that that is crazy i'm like you're
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] first of all just
forget your kids man whatever i'm not
taking my shoes off you crazy i can't
that's why
no sir but i i i
mean i've heard stories of guys i should
go to work and don't realize that yeah
crazy like your baby's in the car
because it was your turn to drop them
off at school for the first time ever
but you get in the car you just do your
route to work and you get out of the car
and you go and the baby's in the back
that can't be happening that much i mean
i've heard the stories and i know they
have the technology that you know to
prevent it but that's you know the fact
that it's enough that that should come
standard now that it just says check the
back shouldn't it come standard again
urban legends like we got high on acid
and we brought home a kid because we
thought it was a troll you ever hear
that one no the story i heard in there
on the weekends all my friends told me
the same thing it was like we went out
we dropped acid for the first time on
the walk home we saw a gnome and it was
a troll and we were playing with it in
the morning and there was a baby in the
in the living room and i was i was like
yeah that's probably the same story as
the guy who leaves the baby
hopefully that's [ __ ] broncos
i'm just [ __ ] empty in the clip on
this episode we're talking about all
sorts of [ __ ] you're a dirt bag all your
friends are dirtbags jesus i don't i
don't make podcast appearances really
that's why i come through it's like what
do you feel honestly
i got a bunch of [ __ ] that i want to get
off my chest all right this this one cut
me deep this is from louis uh long time
first time is it garbage you use the
comforter set package as storage for
example i have a bunch of random cables
in there [ __ ] yeah which i thought
not for the company yeah like you saved
them don't throw that out your bag
that's a quality bag
i got about three of them on my closet
with like books and [ __ ] clothes
anything put a big sandwich i just i
just remembered another thing you're
gonna kill me for this is maybe one of
the most garbage appearances from
anybody ever this is up here yeah we
went to philly for our show a couple
weeks ago also go check out one of the
kfc live shows 100 yeah it is it's
really rounding into like a nice show
when we first started we didn't know
what we're doing we did the one in new
york yeah just having stopped violent
guys in philly
um
so i have also you said you had me on we
were performing at the one in new york
and we couldn't even get in the [ __ ]
building do you remember that we're
standing in line we couldn't get in you
guys are on stage we're about to go up
and we can't get in and i'm like i'm on
the show people are like get babe big
man
we know
i was embarrassed the folks in philly
lived up to their reputation
it was so funny we get to this spot and
there's a girl in the ticket window and
she's like
can i help you and i was like because we
just walked in it was early and i was
like we're we're on the show tonight and
she was like great story and i was like
oh i just i just didn't want you
thinking we're like people watching she
said great no but she but she was like
and so i was like okay so we're gonna go
and then we get like to the next door at
the theater and this guy is like whoa
like whoa where are you going i was like
we're part of the show again he's like
we don't give a [ __ ] he's like you got
to go around all the way back we walk in
there's another security guard he was
like yeah whatever it was just so philly
that i was like we're all like oh hi
like we're so excited to be here tonight
and they're like shut the [ __ ] up i
don't know you [ __ ] you're
moving yeah uh but uh uh anyway i don't
even know where i was [ __ ] oh oh the
reason why i'm i'm extra garbage so i
have like nice luggage
and then i'm talking uh away promo code
kfc yeah everything he got is freebies
so uh it's like a nice like rolling
whatever right
yeah i have nice luggage and then i said
that like you bought it that's why i
used no no no no my point being i have i
don't have it it's in the back of the
rental car i don't have anything in
between so i'm not like packing up
[ __ ] luggage to go to philly and a
lot of the i used to have like nice
duffel bags and [ __ ] that have kind of
become kid's bags sure i know and so i
got nothing i don't even have a backpack
anymore because that's where their
[ __ ] ipads go the kids are faking
everything for me but i'm also just
going for a night playing it cool this
guy's losing
i'm going for just a night
and i just took a
shirt and some boxers and a pair of
pants tossed it in a reusable
grocery bag the one you paid 45 cents
for or whatever yeah they're awesome
though i mean they're they're they're
better than the plastic bags that's what
you say you don't look like such a dirt
ball get to the place and i you know we
get we pull up in the chat explorer tell
like that yeah that's the thing it's
like i grabbed the bag and tried it's
like what is that and i was like
my my stuff it's my clothes and he was
like holy [ __ ]
i was like yeah i'm not proud of this
one and then he told it on stage and i
was like [ __ ] yeah like that one
this one i'm like sweating on stage
being like god damn it's really
embarrassing yeah i might i gotta get it
i gotta get a duffel bag or some [ __ ]
the first two trips we took for live
shows fully brought a tote bag instead
of i was gonna say you guys can't be
[ __ ] you know travel in the world
we've gotten better because we travel so
much yeah so it's like i mean the first
couple of times a month i remember
yelling at toby over something or
something i'm like get a [ __ ] duffel
bag we travel every week yeah that's
that's true when i was a kid i went on a
you know we rarely didn't go on any long
vacations but i went i think with my
girlfriend's family or another family
and like i had a bag that had like duct
tape oh yeah and my mom was like you
just embarrassed the family like you
just like like sullied our family name
by going on a trip but you see people
checking into like a hotel or whatever
like they have like the bet they have
the luggage cart and there's like
plastic bags yeah yeah i mean
like
it's a bad loaf of bread
yikes bag of glass
all right oh man uh all right let's see
let's do one more here and then we gotta
get out of here
uh this one's from uh murdoch were you
ever the target of a whose kid is this
when yelled in a crowd
that's a good one
i don't think i've ever squirting the
ketchup into his mouth
i don't think i've ever been a who's kid
is this i've definitely caused a couple
of
i've definitely been walked back to my
mom
being like have you ever been like lost
in the department store sort of thing
never really lost k-mart still scares me
i was gonna say that's scary man oh it's
a scary one because it was the 80s and
it was just around the time when that
kid got snatched john walsh's kid adam
and they like bro we had to go get
fingerprinted and [ __ ] i was like oh
here we go this is because you your mom
went this way and you're just really
playing in between the clothes i was
being a dick or something you get
distracted in a camera you're like
looking at the toys a little bit later
she goes out of the aisle you think she
makes a laugh she goes right this fella
making fun of me and my friends for
losing the kid in the car your mom's
losing you and [ __ ] k-mart huh it was
too early
she was in the smoking section
they were all taking leads what do you
want
who's who's good is this have you have
you you not lost a kid but you you know
has there been i mean we have i just had
one this weekend on the beach we were
there and they were like where's [ __ ]
steve at everyone's looking like oh he's
over there
those moments everybody and then yeah
i'm sitting there i'm about six [ __ ]
hard seltzers deep and i'm like at what
point do i i have to get up and say yeah
look you know what i mean right like at
one point everybody
should be like all right here we go
i'm out there finish this up knock back
a sandwich take a leak i'm booking and
i'll be on i'll be on the posse i'll be
there about 45 guys once once once these
swells die down i'm gonna come help you
look for the kid my mom my mom got
yelled at by i think a fireman or
something like that i stopped the parade
in in my hometown
because you know
it makes so much sense i don't know why
but of course you stopped the parade you
were like it was like a local small
parade but you know they i don't know if
they still do but they used to throw
candy like real shitty candy you ran it
um i ran out i was in the front of a
[ __ ] uh fire truck just like
like like a like a like a dog throwing
the treat like i gotta get the candy
yeah
it was like tiananmen square
the guy got out there like what's going
on because it stopped the whole parade
whose fat kid is this
whose little fat tub of lord is this guy
that is [ __ ] funny yeah my mom's
running out what the [ __ ] i grabbed me
and ripped me out of the street i don't
think i've had that yet uh like a
multiple like
these uh
see some of these families from you know
maybe from other countries that have
leashes on
because it's just like i think if you're
alone and it's like you know hold my
hand they're like no i don't want to
hold your hand next thing you know
they're [ __ ] walking in the street
and it's like i just had a little bungee
like you wink you know the other day we
almost got
this guy was whipping down city island
avenue in the bronx it was a like drag
racing a guy a motorcycle and a car and
they were dawning at each other as they
were going we had the light i had to
like literally grab my kids like run out
of the way jesus and i was even if i had
a leash
fishing rod see if you see a dog on a
leash no problem you see a kid on a
leash
team leash safety i get it i can kind of
get it i just put up an electric fence
around the house what are you going to
do
you could check them out they're good
before we go we were talking about big
crowds i don't know why i got this vibe
off you have you ever put a girl on your
shoulders not a concert oh bro yeah
again he's not fun i'm not no
it's it's
yeah i put you up there for a minute and
i'd be like lady i'm gassed yeah the
bird usually shows you
that's that's the kfc style show
[Applause]
harry check out these yeah that's a very
specific type of guy in girl yeah yeah
for sure and i'm not either
usually find them at an olive garden
car show
baseball card store those those kind of
typical places yeah
buddy we [ __ ] love gentlemen yeah i i
feel like that was a therapy session
they need to get all right
i'm gonna go out like a steak dinner
tonight somewhere nice [ __ ] you guys
i'll have the plastic fork please thank
you
ladies and gentlemen kevin clancy what
do you want the folks out there to know
we got the barstool we got the kfc radio
if you go to kfc radio on any of our
social media i think there's about a
hundred tickets left to our chicago show
it's almost sold out
it's it's a really good fun show it's a
great time
so there's like 100 tickets left for
that uh we'll uh we'll be putting more
on sale soon
we're going to come to like the ocean
city area in late september there's a
music festival in maryland yeah yeah
there's a music festival going on with
some of the guys from barcelona plants
we'll be in that uh so kfc radio on
youtube kfc barstool is where i put up a
one-minute man
um
and yeah oh and then uh we got a mets
podcast that we're trying to grow so if
you're a baseball fan and a mets fan
it's called we gotta believe it's gonna
be a good year for the mezzies yes it is
not so much for the
yesterday in the philadelphia i wish you
all the luck in the world i know that's
that's very nice of you because he's
around
he's just trying to i like it yeah no i
don't watch the mets
[ __ ] you man i don't hate when people
say that it's like why don't you hate
them i don't hate [ __ ] you
i enjoy them we're going i'm going to
make sure you know i like buck show
walter yeah uncle buck he's the man dude
not bad what do you got for him uh we're
going to be announcing more dates coming
up oh yeah uh we have buffalo detroit
and uh
pittsburgh come see us uh come out
buffalo detroit pittsburgh that is
absolutely that's funny yeah that's
that's the armpit of america baby
let's go salt to the earth june be nice
and hot enjoy that goddamn patreon baby
yeah gang we love you we'll see you next
week